bienvenidos a la presentación de torca y
si viste el vídeo donde presentamos el
centro de masa vimos un poquito de que
es a lo que se refiere el concepto de
torca y ahora lo haremos con mucho más
detalle en general del vídeo de centro
de masa aprendimos que por ejemplo si
tenemos una regla lo que quizás debería
ponerle un poquito más a la derecha
digamos que tenemos esta regla
muy bien ahí está una regla y supongamos
que bueno de hecho podemos ver que el
centro de masas justo coincidía con el
centro geométrico verdad hasta la mitad
de esta distancia y a la mitad de la
distancia vertical entonces si nosotros
tenemos esta regla y que al cual ya
encontramos su centro de masa vamos a
suponer que le aplicamos una fuerza
directamente al centro de masa entonces
lo que obtuvimos y que de hecho fue lo
que lo que estuvimos trabajando en el
vídeo anterior es que si aplicamos esta
fuerza directamente al centro de masa
toda la regla se desplazará de la misma
forma que si el centro de masa se
desplazará es decir si a lo mejor el
centro de masa se empieza a trasladar
aquí toda la regla se traslada de la
misma forma muy bien entonces lo que
quedaba pendiente era ver qué pasaba si
la fuerza no era aplicada ahí sino que
por ejemplo la fuerza fuera aplicada de
este lado que ay qué pasa si por ejemplo
esta regla está
libremente en el espacio verdad y lo que
vimos es que esta regla en realidad
debería rotar alrededor del centro de
masa verdad debería rotar alrededor del
centro de masa y esto no necesariamente
es único del centro de masa por ejemplo
si nosotros tuviéramos una regla que a
lo mejor no se go o en vez de una regla
pueden pensar como que esta es la
manecilla de un reloj y digamos que está
fijo aquí digamos que como todos los
relojes están fijos en algún punto este
no necesariamente es el centro de masa
pero digamos que aquí hay este digamos
este pivote o no sé este este pulcro
digamos ok entonces si piensas que esto
es como una manecilla y que aplicamos
una fuerza nuevamente de este lado pues
vuelve a ocurrir lo mismo esta regla
empieza a girar en esta dirección
alrededor de nuestro eje de rotación
digamos o de nuestro de nuestro pivote
verdad entonces esto en realidad tiene
que ver con la fuerza que estamos
aplicando así
a distancia del centro verdad y esto es
justamente lo que conocemos como thor
que tiene que ver con eso y la torca y
que vamos a denotar con la letra todo se
define simplemente como la fuerza que
aplicamos por la distancia por la
distancia ahora cual fuerza y cual
distancia pues la fuerza es justamente
esta que aplicamos sobre este objeto y
la distancia y de hecho la fuerza no es
cualquiera el punto es que esta fuerza
sea perpendicular a nuestro brazo y
justo esta distancia esta distancia de
aquí es la distancia del brazo de
momento
a distancia
de brazo
de momento muy bien y lo lo importante
de esta fuerza que estamos aplicando es
que tiene que ser perpendicular a este
brazo muy bien oa ésta oa esta distancia
aunque ya este vector entonces uno
podría pensar que a lo mejor la torca
tiene mucho que ver con trabajo pero
esencialmente no es lo mismo aunque
tienen la misma las mismas unidades
verdad porque la fuerza es newtons y la
distancia son metros y esto así era cómo
mediamos el trabajo la energía y que
éstos les llamábamos jules pero esto no
es trabajo esto no es trabajo porque el
trabajo teníamos que la fuerza era
justamente la más bien la distancia era
en la misma dirección de la fuerza aquí
no es exactamente igual ya que son
perpendiculares así que no podemos
hablar que la torca sea un trabajo
aunque tienen las mismas unidades pero
bueno con esto espero que ya hayas
obtenido cierta intuición de cómo de
cómo se trabaja la torca y esto podría
lo mejor
eventualmente ayudarnos a entender
como los caballos de fuerza de los autos
muy bien vamos a hacer un ejemplo
digamos que tengo otra vez una regla muy
bien digamos que tengo otra vez esta
regla
esta mi regla
muy bien
ahí
ahí está la regla ok y digamos que aquí
está fija a la pared aunque hay aquí
está el punto y ahí lo estamos clavando
vamos a aplicar una fuerza una fuerza
digamos a 10 metros 10 metros vamos a
aplicar una fuerza de 5 newtons muy bien
y recordemos que la fuerza debe ser
perpendicular a este vector digamos
vamos a decirlo de distancia verdad que
va de este centro donde estamos fijando
hasta el punto donde aplicamos la fuerza
muy bien entonces calcular la torca es
muy sencillo verdad la torca vimos cómo
está definido es fuerza que son 5
newtons por la distancia por la
distancia que son 10 metros y entonces
uno simplemente concluye que la torca
son 50 newtons por met verdad
y aquí lo interesante que hay que notar
es que bueno por supuesto intuitivamente
podemos ver que si aplicamos una fuerza
de este lado entonces esta regla o esta
manecilla como quieran verlo va a girar
en dirección contraria a las manecillas
a como giran las manecillas del reloj y
así es como en física definimos si una
torsión es positiva verdad una torsión
es positiva si el efecto de rotación que
genera es en dirección contraria a las
manecillas del reloj verdad y esto
seguiría rotando de esta forma ahora
bien si nosotros aplicamos una fuerza
del lado izquierdo entonces el la regla
giraría justo en la dirección de las
manecillas del reloj y entonces
estaríamos diciendo que la torca que se
produce es negativa verdad entonces esta
es digamos la convención que vamos a
utilizar y vamos a dejarlo de hecho así
no no vamos a entrar por ahora todo el
producto cruz de la torca y cosas así
más elevadas simplemente por qué va
va más allá de las intenciones de estos
vídeos así que luego cuando veamos
física con mucho más rigor matemático
entonces sí podremos entrar a estas
cuestiones pero aquí el detalle es que
sabemos que esta regla va a rotar y creo
que al menos pues bueno no tenemos las
herramientas para medir cuánto o a qué
velocidad o demás por ahora pero al
menos es bueno saber que va a rotar
ahora qué pasaría si suponemos que esto
no rota es decir que tal que alguien que
está aplicando esta fuerza también
podemos encontrar a alguien que se
encuentra de este otro lado digamos a
cinco metros que también está aplicando
una fuerza una fuerza f muy bien ahora
si suponemos que esta regla está en
equilibrio es decir no se mueve no está
rotando quiere decir que la torca neta
es cero porque no hay una tasa de cambio
de ello verdad entonces si la si la
torca neta es
vamos a ver qué es lo que ocurre cuál
sería la fuerza necesaria para aplicar
en este punto para que el para que la
regla no esté rotando y entonces si nos
fijamos bueno ya que ya que mencionamos
que la torca neta debe ser cero quiere
decir que la torca de este lado más la
de este lado debe dar cero cual es la de
este lado pues ya vimos que son 50
newton por metro verdad eran 5 que es la
fuerza por 10 que es la distancia y
ahora sumamos la torca producida de este
otro lado la torca sería sería bueno
pensemos si aplicamos una fuerza del
lado izquierdo esta regla va a girar en
dirección de las manecillas del reloj
quiere decir que esto lleva un signo
menos verdad
o digamos podemos pensarlo en más y que
la fuerza es digamos menos efe aquí vaya
el signo menos porque gira en dirección
de las manecillas del reloj y esto
multiplica la distancia que es 5 y esto
debe ser 0 porque la torca neta debe ser
0 así que qué es lo que tenemos tenemos
de este lado 5 por 10 que son 50 menos
- 5 efe que es igual a 0 quiere decir
que 5 efe es igual a 50 y si dividimos
entre 5 de ambos lados tenemos que la
fuerza es de 10 newtons verdad la fuerza
es de 10 minutos y aquí puedes darte
cuenta que es algo muy parecido a la
ventaja mecánica que vimos hace algunos
vídeos y si eso te resulta un poco
extraño te invito a que veas esos vídeos
porque es muy similar verdad aquí
teníamos una distancia de 10 metros lo
cual si por ejemplo aquí teníamos a un
no sé a algún señor que fuera muy débil
necesitaba cinco newtons de fuerza en
cambio si está compitiendo con alguien
que sea más fuerte de hecho necesita 10
newtons para mantener esto en equilibrio
el detalle es que mientras aquí tenemos
la mitad de la fuerza del del lado
izquierdo tenemos que emplear esa fuerza
en el doble de distancia de verdad y al
revés aquí tenemos que aplicar a la
mitad débil de la distancia que tenemos
del lado derecho el doble de fuerza
entonces es muy similar a la ventaja
mecánica y aquí es en donde la torca es
útil pues si no está girando esta regla
quiere decir que la torca es cero y
entonces puedes despejar alguna de las
variables que te interesa muy bien
entonces por aquí vamos a dejarlo en
este vídeo nos vemos en el próximo